thanks everyone uh joining this session
on a saturday afternoon
and i think it's close to lunch time or
fast lunch time so yeah thanks for being
here
and so this tutorial is about our uh
toolkit it's called uncertainty
quantification 360. i'm prasanna thierry
and i have my colleagues um samyang
ghosh and jerry navrati from ibm
research
and so we will be presenting this
toolkit um
so just before we start these are some
useful links so we have a web
page where you can get more details of
the toolkit and there is a nice demo
which i will briefly describe
and this is the github link and this is
for
installation right and
we do have a channel in the pi data
workspace for uncertainty quantification
so you can ask questions there and we
can have conversations there
later on but for more longer term we
also have a separate workspace which is
at this link if you go here you can get
an invite get on this workspace and
there's a separate channel for uq 360.
all right so um
so let's
get right into it right so this is a
quick agenda of
today's session i will start with
describing some basic concepts of
uncertainty quantification
introduce what we mean by uncertainty
quantification especially um with
respect to ai
models and so on
briefly describe the toolkit and i'll
jump into the interactive web experience
that we have and after that we'll take a
brief pause
and you can install the package if you
like because the following sessions will
be by samya and jury and they'll deep
dive into some of the uncertainty
quantification algorithms and metrics so
if you would like to install the package
you could do that so that you can follow
along with the hands-on tutorials that
jiri and sony have
and if there is time i will briefly
touch upon how uncertainty
quantification is
also related to other pillars of
trustworthy ai
specifically how we can
use it for explainability and fairness
and so on
all right
okay so yeah so what question right so
what do we mean by uncertainty
quantification ai so um i mean simply
it's the ability for an ai model to say
i'm unsure right so uh think of critical
systems like in medical domain and so on
right so if you have a system
uh that is trying to predict the
presence of pneumonia let's say um so
we don't just want a system which gives
us a best guess right so to really make
the predictions actionable we need some
measure of uncertainty or confidence
from the model also right
so
uh so how it would look like right for
example if this is a binary
classification task if the job of the
system is to predict the presence of
pneumonia and no pneumonia then we also
want to know the model confidence course
right so for example in this specific
case for this particular instance we see
that the model is not very confident so
even though it's predicting no pneumonia
but the confidence is not really high
so what a user in this case for example
a doctor could do is to sort of reject
the model's prediction because it's not
really confident so they can either go
to some other expert go to some other
system collect more features and so on
so if you have access to good quality
uncertainty estimates you
add a layer of safety a layer of
transparency and sort of enables human
ai collaboration right so um so it's
kind of critical especially in systems
like medical
domains and
justice domains hiring let's say
wherever there is a end user who's
affected by the model decisions we need
these kind of
outputs our confidence scores or
uncertain scores from the mark right
and the other aspect is the model
improvement itself right so if the model
can exhibit or provide us some good
confidence measures then we can get some
guidance in how to improve the model
right so active learning is one such
framework so
you can have a model if it gives you
uncertainty scores you can look at the
region of the input where the model is
least confident and try to collect data
from that space right so it's useful
in being acting as a guide for model
improvement right
so i mean the question now comes is uh
we have a model that can give someone
certainty at sms let's say and do are
they trustworthy right are they reliable
so we need some metrics to measure how
good these uncertainty estimates are
and typically we don't have access to
ground truth uncertainty
scores right so the most common way to
measure how good uncertainties are is
through some surrogate
metrics such as calibration right and
these can look slightly different based
on is it a classification task or a
regression task and so on
and in the classification task
reliability plot is one common uh
approach to
look at how good the uncertainty
estimates are calibrated right
um so
so i'll briefly explain this uh and it
might be useful in the later hands-on
sessions right
so so what is a good uh property of
confidence course or uncertainty
estimates right so the classification
case let's say there's a binary
classification task and if the model is
predicting let's say for a certain group
of instances a score of 0.8 right for
along with its predictions then a well
calibrated uncertainty score confidence
course would have an average accuracy of
80 percent
on those set of instances right so
that's that's what we expect so
uh so
if a well calibrated system the curve
the reliability uh curve should be this
diagonal line right
and if you see this blue
model here for example if you take all
the instances which had confidence score
as 0.8
this average score is 0.6 right so this
means that the model is overconfident it
is not well calibrated similarly if uh
the model had a lot more accuracy than
its average confidence then it is
underconfident in some sense and both
could be
harmful or disadvantageous in certain
situations right so we need these kind
of metrics to measure how good the
uncertainty scores are and we want them
to well calibrate it right
and similarly uh this might be even
easier to understand in a regression
case and in the regression case uh
typically we measured calibration
through these two concepts so the first
one is the prediction interval coverage
probability also called as miss rate and
the second one is the mean prediction
interval width or also called the
bandwidth right so let's look at these
two examples right so
this is one model this is another model
um let's say there is only one input
feature and we have a scalar output and
the blue is the ground truth right in
both cases and if you see the the dots
are the mean estimates of the model the
best cases of the model and they are
quite similar in both cases but the
prediction intervals in this case the
upper and lower
quantiles are kind of varying in these
two models right and if you look in this
case the uncertainty is quite large
for most instances here it's small for
most instances right and we can compute
this picture score or the prediction and
double coverage probability by looking
at all the instances
where the the prediction interval
actually covered the ground truth right
so this is the desirable property right
so you have a prediction you get a
prediction interval the upper and lower
quantiles we want the ground to actually
cover uh be covered in those
prediction intervals right so in this
case three instances are covered and one
is missing so this is the picp score is
3x4 or 0.75 right and you can also
compute the average width of these
prediction intervals and which is which
tells you how uncertain the model is on
an average
similarly for this model you can see
that only one data point is covered
by these prediction intervals so here
the pice score will be one by four or
point one five point two five
whereas its
uncertainty on an average is low
let's say 15 but we know that this is
not very trustworthy right because its
coverage probabilities are not great
so we'll come back to these concepts
when we go through the web demo and also
when julie and samya will talk about the
different
quantification algorithms
okay so
so
just a quick uh primer on why these
uncertainties may not be well calibrated
right so it could be a number of reasons
but one reason could be that the model
doesn't capture all sources of
uncertainties right so what are the
different sources of uncertainty so um
one is they could be inherent
variability in the data itself right so
given a particular feature value the
outcome could vary slightly each time
and this is called as data uncertainty
and this could be hard to reduce just by
observing more data samples right so if
we observe more data samples across all
the regions of the input space then we
can reduce the model uncertainties what
that means is the model has seen
trading samples in all the uh places so
um so it's much more confident right but
if there are some regions where which
the model has not seen any instances
there will be large and there should be
large uncertainty in those regions
all right um
so um
so yeah so that brings to this next
point right so we need metrics and we
need algorithms which can uh
which have diverse properties right so
they should be able to capture data
uncertainty they should be able to
capture model uncertainty and there are
some trade-offs in the sense that uh how
much computational power we have how
much data we have and so on so each
situation might require us to use a sort
of model with different properties
and if you're building a model from
scratch then you can go with some sort
of intrinsic algorithm right which
captures uncertainty
by its design right
but
it's also possible that we
have a model that is already trained and
then its calibration properties our
unsurging properties are not so great
then we want some sort of algorithms
which can improve their calibration
their uncertainty properties and
one class of algorithms are something
called as meta models which jury will
describe a little bit more in detail and
then we also have infinitesimal
jackknife which is an interesting
approach to extract uncertainties in a
post-hoc manner which jira will cover in
detail
um and also an important point we
should need to communicate the
uncertainty to the end users uh in a
meaningful way right and each user might
have different um
desired properties of how it is
communicated to them right so some might
want the full sort of
gamut of the distribution the others may
just want you to convey some sort of
gist of the model predictions in a much
more digestible way right so we need to
think about the end users and how should
we communicate this uncertainty
so i mean so that's what the toolkit is
trying to provide so there is a workflow
for uncertainty quantification and the
toolkit tries to provide building blocks
for each step of this workflow right so
um just to go through this flowchart so
if you have a mo if you don't have a
model then
you start out uh you have a choice of
using intrinsic
uq algorithms right a model which can
give you uncertainty by default
and if you see if first you evaluate how
good these uncertainties are if it is
not so great then you can try to
calibrate it using some sort of post hoc
uncertainty quantification algorithms
and you can complete this loop and when
you're satisfied with the uncertainty
estimates quality then you can think of
how do i best communicate this to the
users right
so um
so
let's look at the web interface now and
which will sort of give a very quick
example of this workflow
go to the browser
all right
so um
try to zoom in a little bit
okay so um so this is a very simple
example right so there are two personas
here there is a data scientist and there
is a house seller and the the data
scientist is trying to build a model to
break the
prices um of the houses right and then
the house seller will look at the
model's predictions and its uncertainty
estimates and trying to either accept or
reject the model prediction right
so
um so as i said there are different
steps in this workflow right so data
scientists choose a model which has up
capability then they can measure how
good these uncertainty estimates are
they can do some sort of post hoc
recalibration to improve the uq estimate
quality
they can use the uncertainty estimates
in some sense to guide
in terms of how to improve the model
and finally
they can the data scientists can hand
over the model or
have a way of communicating the
uncertainty to the house seller right
so let's look at these steps quickly
um
so so this is a
sort of
thinking that data scientists can have
right so they're starting to build a new
model they have a choice of using
intrinsic algorithms um
the
the data set is relatively small
so they can
they have freedom to choose
approach um so in this case the design
is tools let's say gaussian processes
which can capture both data and model
uncertainty right so
um
and so the date the house seller
sets a desired picp score the coverage
probability
of 95 what that means is they want a
model
which will
emit prediction intervals which will
contain the ground truth 95 percent of
time that's the desired requirement
right
so
so once the model is built then you can
compute the pictp score
and to get more insight into the
models performance they can also
look at how the pictp score looks across
different features right so we assume
that this model simple model has just
two features uh number of rooms and
crime rate and we are trying to predict
the house price and you can see that um
in most cases the pictp score
is
below the desired level of 95 right and
it's especially bad when the number of
rooms are large
so
then the data scientists can use a
recalibration technique so in this case
we use the uncertainty characteristic
curve which jury will go into much more
detail and by using this recalibration
procedure the data scientists can
improve the coverage probability the
pict score about the desired level of 95
percent right
and the price that we had to pay here is
that the average uncertainty has gone up
the the average bandwidth has gone up a
little bit
so
um
let's go back
uh let me skip the improvement of the
model part for the
sake of time and just look at the final
step right so assuming the data
scientists happy with the model and now
let's
look at how the uncertainties
communicated right so
there are different choices here i mean
the first choice um
is
just
give it verbally right so you have the
best guess from the model and then you
can communicate its prediction interval
using this
these plus or minus
quantile ranges right
it's also possible to give the whole
distribution
this might be
useful to get much more detailed
insights into the uncertainty for this
particular instance
uh but
it might also be much more desirable to
show something called as quantile dot
plot which shows the relative
likelihood values for different uh
possible house prices right and this
much this could be much more digestible
so
um
yeah let me just show a few other things
on this website and then i can take a
pause and uh answer some questions
um so so this website has some other uh
useful things that you might
care to look at
as i mentioned you can click on this
link and join the
slack community
for
if you're interested this was the web
demo link and we have an overview here
which um
sort of describe the same thing that i
mentioned the different capabilities and
how to use uncertainty quantification
and so on
and we sort of have it's
some a little bit detailed guidance on
when to use which algorithm and the
metrics as well
we also have a detailed guide on
uncertainty communication so do check
this out
the glossary describes the terms that
i've been using
more formally
and
some of the recent papers and links to
the tutorials which will be covered in a
bit
and the home page also has links to the
tutorials the different algorithms and
and
the
different metrics as well right and
the links in the top here will take you
to the
the api docs and you can get more
details about each algorithm and metric
um and finally this will take you to the
github page right
so um
yeah so let me take a pause here and
if you
want to start setting up the
the package you can follow the
instructions here uh it might be
desirable to be the local installation
so that you can get access to this
examples that jiri insomnia will cover
uh all right so let me take a pause here
for five minutes and see if there are
questions and uh press and i don't know
if you can hear me can you yeah i can
hear you now yeah okay
i have a question this is the moderator
this is related to
the output of a
binary logistic regression model let's
say for example it outputs
0.55 as your indicator
and one and
i mean the probability from 0 to 1 is 55
when do you say
i contrast oh i can cut off maybe at 0.6
and say oh that's enough it's uncertain
it's not
it's
i'm asking basically can you just use
the output of the model score instead of
using a quantification of uncertainty
when do you choose to use an picp for
example instead of just using the output
of the model score
right so the pictp score is more
applicable for the uh the regression
case right so if i go back to the slides
for a brief bit but if you look at the
classification case right and i mean the
desirable property is if the model has a
confidence of 0.55 like for a particular
instance then uh
if you want to measure how good or how
trustworthy that prediction is you will
have to look at all the instances
where the model gave a score of 0.55 and
you need to check what is the accuracy
of the model right if the accuracy is 55
percent on all those instances then it
is well calibrated so it's at least the
uncertainty is trustworthy but then the
i think the other question that you
related to is like when you accept this
when we use this prediction or not
because it's uncertain and that's where
the decision maker will come into the
picture right so they have to decide
what is the cutoff for them and
like how much uncertainty is uh sort of
acceptable to them so that's i think
that's like an application dependent
question
yes and then um do you have any one
specific
uq
metric that you say oh i recommend this
for this particular situation all the
time
instead of having several metrics
yes that's that's a good point i think
for classification like uh expected
calibration error which sort of is like
a summary of this reliability plot
that's like the most common um metric to
use
um so that's that's a good um and
definitely a good metric to always see
for classification cases there is also
something called as risk versus
rejection plot so you're trying to see
like if i
reject certain fraction of samples where
there is high uncertainty do i reduce
the model error right so the expectation
is as you reject instances which have
high uncertainty the remaining instances
where the uncertainty was low we expect
that the error will go down compared to
all the instances right so that's also a
good
metric to see for classifications and
for regression i think these two are
typically
used quite a lot to
see how
so first i mean this is basically
telling you
how trustworthy the uncertainties are
right do they cover the ground truth or
not and this tells you like how
uncertain the model is so we want both
of these to be small right because if
there is too much uncertainty then again
it's not really useful and then jiri
will pro go into much more detail into
something new that we have which is
called uncertainty characteristic of
which is
trying to be
agnostic to these sort of different
operating points right which which will
give you a much more
concise and
deeper sort of
look into the scores and maybe that that
might be something that you could use
um prasanna just a comment i see in the
chat that somebody is trying to clone
our repo and they are using github
github.ibm.com i'm not sure
i might have missed it but uh if you
check on the link that you posted
just for the record that we have it
correct oh this should be the link um
yeah that's the link
uh so it's the public github github.com
not
github.ibm.com
oh apologies if i have posted that
somewhere this should be the public link
is there a question
oh yeah sorry i just asked about um the
whole recalibration thing where i like
the idea where your objective there was
to maximize picp um where you mentioned
that the trade-off was the increase of
the other acronym that starts with m
but my main
concern is that
by doing so the analyst is ignoring
possible bias of the model i believe
that
jiri is addressing that but i just think
um that's better practice to try to
resolve bias issues than just uh
conflating uncertainty so what's your
opinion about that
yeah that's that's a i think that's a
good point um
um so when you say uh
buyers do you mean like the the fairness
issues or you mean in general um imagine
your data
imagine your data is a quadratic and
you're using a linear model
okay that's obvious bias and you're just
going to conflate your uncertainties
where you're totally off because um
because you're not using the right
model
right yeah i think that's a good point
um
but sometimes we don't have liberty to
change the model right i skipped a step
where we have to improve the model uh so
that's so that's definitely wherever
it's possible we should improve the
model right but when it's not i think at
least we can make sure that
whatever uncertainties we provide
those at least have good coverage
guarantees right and
i think
at least that's something that is
desirable when you can't have the right
model and that's what i would say but
you're right i think
uh if we have the freedom to improve the
model we should definitely do that
okay great thank you i have another
ask another question
yeah yeah
so something that i felt was missing for
me in terms of the
um
the
probability uncertainty it's just
something i dabbled with a while ago so
let's say you have a neural network and
it tells you
a probability and but then if you use a
drop out layers like that and you ask it
again it might give you a totally
different uh uh probability and so i
find myself using something called
mutual information
is that something uh um that what i mean
by that is the reliability that if you
change um your model just a bit you
you'll get similar uh probabilities
because for example um
if on average you'll get a
0.5 probability you don't know if that
is because it's consistently around the
neighborhood of 0.5 or perhaps it's
around
half the time
zero and half around you know zero or
0.1 and half the time around 0.9 to 1.
so that's where mutual information i
found is useful and and maybe you can
point out if that's used in in your
mechanism
yeah i haven't seen that method but that
sounds quite interesting but i just want
to point out like we have a lot of
different um algorithms that's besides
the reason right some algorithms are
deficient in some and some algorithms
are better in some cases but there's no
universally
good algorithm right so we do have like
ensembles the the dropout nc dropout one
do fall in this we have fully patient
ones so i think what you're mentioning
could be something interesting to look
at and try to include but i haven't seen
that before yeah
maybe you can share something i'll
follow up on stuck
all right so maybe um let me hand it
over to insomya and we can do a deep
dive into the infinitesimal jackknife
and how to use that for uncertainty
quantification
and yeah feel free to uh message and i
can respond to any installation issues
okay thanks lisa now let me let me start
sharing
okay uh so thanks everyone uh for uh as
for senator for joining us at this lunch
hour and thanks for signing up for the
overview
so i will talk about a specific method
that's implemented in our toolbox uh
it's called the infinitesimal jackknife
it's a particular way to get the
parametric uncertainties out uh through
cheap but fairly accurate approximation
to the classical statistical procedure
of jackknife
uh so let's assume that we are in the
supervised learning setting so we are
given some data set d uh and we have n
data points uh the covariates so the
features are denoted by x here and the
responses of the labels are denoted by y
and as a standard in a supervised
learning problem we're interested in
learning the functional mapping from x
to y we're going to assume that this
functional mapping is parameterized by
some set of parameters theta so if you
have a logistic regression model these
are the sets of weights of a logistic
regression model for example
okay so we know how to learn these
models it's fairly well understood so
we'll simply do some form of empirical
or if you have a regularizer a
regularized risk minimization
that is we'll minimize this particular
equation where the first term
is basically just a summation over
losses at every partic at every data
point so where i'm using the l sub n
theta as a shorthand notation for the
loss evaluated at it at the nth data
point in this case
and r theta is just some regularizer
which is a
function of the
of the parameter theta
so given some data set we can solve this
minimization problem and we end up with
a optimal parameter theta hat
the one thing i do want to emphasize
here is that this theta hat is a
function of your model obviously but
it's also a function of the data set
right like if i had given you a slightly
different data set we had solved we
would have solved the same minimization
problem but would have arrived at a
slightly different theta hat so fairly
obvious stuff but we'll make this
explicit in our notation and express
theta hat as a function of d
and d being the data set
okay so now we can ask about the
uncertainty in in the parameters
stemming from having observed a data set
d a sample uh
data set d from some population but not
having observed the entire population
itself
in other words if i
uh i observed a particular data set d
but how would my parameters have changed
if i had observed a slightly different
version of that data set b
so statisticians have worked on these
problems for the longest time
so and the math here is very well
understood so the standard way of
dealing with this is to take your data
set d
and
perturb this data set d many times uh in
in some way and for each of these
perturbed data set d you'd fit a uh
you'd refret the model or you do redo
that minimization problem that i was
talking about
so for instance one way you could put up
these data sets would be by creating
variants of the datasets where we're
dropping out one data point at a time so
here d superscript one indicates the
same data set as d except that the first
data point has been dropped out so we go
from x to y two to x and y n
i could repeat this and drop out the
second data point and so on and so forth
until i drop out the last data point
so this is a particular type of free
sampling scheme that is extremely
uh
that is widely used so procedures like
the jackknife and even something like
they leave one out cross-validation
which i'm sure everyone here is familiar
with
basically employ this
this sort of resampling scheme
now once we have these
s or n different resampled variants of
the data set for each of them we are
going to fit
fit
fit our model so do the minimization
problem again
and then we'll get slightly different
values of theta for each of these data
sets and these slightly different values
of theta give us a sense of the spread
of thetas or
a sense of uncertainty in the theta that
arise from having only observed a sample
rather than the entire population so by
looking at the spread it gives you a
notion of uncertainty
okay so this
perturb and refit approach is
widely used in practice right like the
jackknife bootstrap variants of
cross-validation can all be sort of
instances of this approach where you
just re
where you're just changing the way you
re-sample uh the data sets the way you
create the data sets d superscript one
through the superscript test
and then as long as we know how to fit
our model to one data set we basically
doing this is procedurally trivial right
like i just have to fit this to my s
different data sets so this thing is
procedurally trivial but turns out that
it is since it requires as different
fits it can be computationally quite
expensive especially for large modern
data sets where you have a lot of data
points this can be prohibitively
expensive
so the infinitesimal jack knife which
i'll talk about right now
provides a fast approximation
to the scheme so instead of refitting
so you'll still create you still create
a bunch of free sample datasets d12
through ds but instead of refitting for
each of these data sets you'd refit the
model exactly once on the original
dataset so you'd refit the model to this
guide d
and then we can approximate
which involved the approximation
involves just a single matrix
multiplication
what the parameter values would be at
all of the other datasets d1 through ds
however before i can actually introduce
what the
ij mechanism is we need a little more
machinery
so first we'll consider a weighted
version of our original learning problem
uh so
notice that in the second equation right
here the only thing i've changed is now
i have a weight w sub n think of this as
just a real scalar a scalar a real
number
which weights every data point specific
loss function
and then we are going to solve this
weighted optimization problem and one
thing to note now is that theta hat is a
function of both the data set d
which i have not chosen to highlight
here but is also a function of w
so now
it's fairly obvious if i set all my w
sub n's equal to 1 or
in other words like if i use a vector
let's call
n dimensional vector w sub 1 of all ones
and solve the weighted
optimization problem i recover my
original optimization problem right
because you know we're just multiplying
all my loss functions with one so
nothing has really changed
okay
but more interestingly if i set a
particular coordinate of my weight
vector say the nth coordinate of my
weight vector of all ones to zero
and solve the weighted optimization
problem
that
that solution corresponds to solving the
unweighted optimization problem
where the nth data point has been
dropped out
again this is
fairly easy to see because if i set one
of these w sub n's to zero i'm just
taking out the contribution that the nth
data point made to my original
optimization problem so that's like
fitting my original optimization problem
uh with dropping that particular data
point out
we can extend this reasoning uh so
instead of dropping out a single data
point we can imagine dropping out k data
points so that
amounts to setting a bunch of zeros in
this n-dimensional weight vector that i
have where n uh in case i didn't mention
a capital n is the number of changing
points that you
have uh so this allows us to emulate
things like uh
k-fold cross-validation
and we can also think of about making
the weight vector itself random and then
if we draw this weight vector from a
appropriate distribution it allows us to
emulate things like the bootstrap so for
the bootstrap you have to draw it from a
multinomial distribution
okay
so
so we took our original original
learning problem converted into this
weighted learning problem
uh
the weighted learning problem allows us
to express uh
uh the parameters theta as a function of
w
so now the key idea behind infinitesimal
jackknife which is going to allow us to
move away from refitting the models
is basically a taylor series expansion
the idea is that we can approximate the
parameters theta at some arbitrary
weight vector
which is close to the vector of all ones
by performing a taylor series expansion
around the vector of all ones
the first order taylor says
approximation
is
sometimes called the influence function
or the internet decimal jack name they
go they have a couple of different names
and there are other higher order terms
obviously in the taylor series expansion
you can include these higher order terms
they come at the expense of more
computation but they give you
increasingly more accurate
approximations
and it is sometimes useful for certain
kinds of perturbations like the
bootstrap to get anything out of these
kinds of approximations you would
probably want the higher order terms
the toolbox currently only implements
the first order data expansion which
nonetheless is accurate and increasingly
accurate with as n where n is the number
of training points uh increases and the
delta w the perturbation
in the weight vector is small
and turns out that
if you work out what this expression is
you end up with a term which looks like
this
where theta hat w1 is the original fit
so this is
having solved the original optimization
problem on the entire training data set
you end up with a parameter
and that parameter is theta hat w1
and then you have a term which involves
the hessian of the model and you have a
term which involves the various
gradients of the model so you typically
have the gradients of the model
because we're typically doing gradient
based fitting
but the additional requirement is that
we have this hessian available so we do
need our models to be twice
differentiable for this sort of
approximation to hold
okay
okay so now with the taylor series
expansion at hand we can finally specify
a algorithm which allows us to basically
refit these models for free by
approximating using the taylor series
approximation
so step one is fit your model once to
the entire data set
right uh so we have to do this anyway
but like we will do it specifically for
enabling this uh approximation happening
to
happen step two is to compute the
hessian of the model on the training set
this uh and invert it uh
the inversion of the hessian
in general takes cubic time in
in the number of parameters in the model
but if the structure in your model
sometimes you can speed this up
but crucially you have to do this only
once
now uh put up your dataset a little bit
for each perturbed data set figure out
what the appropriate weighting is and
these are typically easy to figure out
so for example if you're doing jackknife
your appropriate weighting is just
setting one coordinate of your data
point
to zero
and then use equation one this guy right
here to approximate what theta d sub s
is
and finally repeat steps three and four
as
as often as necessary for each of your
perturbed data sets
so crucially
the expensive bits which is fitting the
model
and computing the inverse of the hessian
need to be done only once
after that you need to be able to
evaluate this equation and you can do
this pretty easily and it involves
really the bottleneck is one matrix
multiplication so this guy which is a p
by p vector p being the number of
parameters in your model
with
a p by n matrix where n is the number of
data points
interestingly if you structure your uh
weights in a way where only a little
only a few of the weight coordinates are
changing from the vector of all ones you
don't even have to do this matrix
multiplication it turns out that you can
just do
a few matrix vector uh
and that's enough
also to say that this can be done pretty
efficiently
uh and that's the algorithm so instead
of doing s refits which can be extremely
expensive we just do
one refit and then
do s matrix vector multiplications uh to
approximate what the parameter values
would be
there are also extensions to this work
which i won't have the time to get into
unfortunately uh this tutorial which
allow you to extend this to structured
data unstructured models so instead of
dropping out data points which are iid
which are independent of all other data
points you can actually drop out times
uh time steps from within a time series
a spatial
sites from within a special extent
okay so without further ado and in the
interest of time i'll just move on to
the demo uh but if you'd like to learn
more about
about all the stuff that i quickly uh
went over in this
in this brief presentation
these are based on primarily on these
two papers one
which came out in yes that's a couple of
years ago on our new reps paper from
last year
beyond beyond the methods that i just
talked about they provide theory which
bounce which allows you to bound the
error in the approximation so that these
things it will tell you when these
things are
are accurate and when they are not
and it also tells you that the error in
the
approximation in the ig approximation go
grows smoothly with the error in the
initial model set
this bit is kind of important because
that allows you to use these sorts of
approximations with stochastic gradient
methods so basically all of modern
machine learning does std style fitting
of these models
it turns out that this theory which says
that
if you don't fit the model initial model
exactly but use stochastic gradient
methods everything would roughly be fine
okay so next i'm going to move on to
this demo uh
it's hosted in the repository under the
exam examples folder so if you'd like to
follow along
this is the
this is the part to the ipad's
unlockable that i'll go over
okay so hopefully everyone can see my
see the ipads and notebook
yeah yes you can see it
okay perfect
okay so again the notebook is hosted in
the examples folder under the infinite
small jackknife
folder and the one that i'm running here
is demo infinite a small jackknife dot
ipython
notebook
okay so for this notebook we are going
to demo it on a simple logistic
regression model so in addition to
importing various stuff that is required
by the uh
by the iga or the infinite decimal
jackknife approximation we are going to
go into utils and input a bunch of
things which allow us the logistics
which provide us the logistic regression
functionality so let me run that
[Music]
okay and we need some data
we could have used whatever data
we wanted for this particular demo i'm
just going to use simulated data
so here
we are going to assume that the data has
been generated by the following
generated procedure
so the covariates are going to be 10
dimensional gaussian distributed random
variables drawn from a zero mean
gaussian with a isotropic covariance
matrix a sigma square for this
particular example has been set to four
i'm going to draw some weights at random
and then i'm going to draw the labels or
the responses from a bernoulli
distribution parameterized by
the sigmoid transformed inner product
between the weight
and the data point x
right
this is all
done in this uh
in this helper function that we have
which is called synthetic lr data
it takes in two inputs n
n is the number of training points and d
d is the dimensionality of the data
that's being generated
it produces four things the covariates
the training covariates the training
responses the test covariates and the
trust responses
the number of test covariates or the
test data once that it generates is 30
of this number so it'll be 300 in this
particular case again this is just for
illustration you can actually set it to
whatever model that you like uh whatever
data that you like to do
like to work with
okay so now that we have some data let's
go ahead and fit our logistic regression
model
so for this purpose we have a utility
function within the logistic regression
class dot fit
and this function takes in four inputs
as you can imagine the training data
goes in the training coverage and the
training targets
along with a initial guess of what the
parameters should be
and a weight vector so i'm passing on
the weight vector because this would
make our life easier when dealing with
the infinite decimal jackknife
sort of approximation
so this weight vector is a vector of
shape 1 and n where n is the number of
training inputs
so here i'm generating that weight
vector right here so this is going to be
a vector of all ones uh of shape one and
uh uh
one and n where n is the number of
training inputs again
uh so if if if this is a vector of all
ones then as you recall from the slides
you end up with the original
minimization problem so doing this fit
is basically doing maximum likelihood
estimation
what this function fit returns are the
estimated parameters after having done
this minimization
for the minimization fit is internally
just calling scipy's minimize function
so that's either using bfgs or lbhgs
depending on the
depending on whatever
sci-fi decides is appropriate for the
problem at hand
and then once we have the parameters we
can ask what the accuracy on the test
data set is um
so for that we have a get test accuracy
function so again fairly standard stuff
so let's just run that
uh so it did something the optimization
terminated successfully and we end up
with a test accuracy of 81 percent this
is fine for a simple linear model again
the goal here is not to push
accuracy numbers but just to illustrate
uh infinite decimals
right so with a reasonable model at hand
we can go ahead and do all the
computations that are necessary for the
infinitesimal jackknife approximation
uh so again recall from the slides we
need two things right like we need the
hessian of the model
so for that we
provide a utility function compute
hessium
uh all of these by the way internally uh
use autodiff tools right like so these
are if you wanted to do this for your
own model and not our particular model
these are
these functions extend to your models as
long as you can auto differentiate
through the model
and we need to compute the gradients so
these could have been stored while
fitting the model but i'm just going to
assume that you did not store the
gradients while fitting the model so we
are going to recompute them and package
them into a jacobian matrix
j
so for that we have another function
compute jacobian these are just utility
functions
and then finally we can call instantiate
the
infinitesimal jackknife object it takes
in
the fit parameters so parameters from
the model having been fed to the entire
training data set
the jacobian matrix the hessian matrix
and a
couple of configuration parameters which
are not particularly important
so i'm just going to skip over what
those are
okay so let's run that
since this was a fairly small
problem so n is thousand and our uh
dimensionality is 10
computing the hessian and inverting it
does not take a lot of time
okay so now we have all the things that
we needed to pre-compute
uh available so we had to do this sort
of heavy lifting of fitting the model
and computing and inverting the hessian
once all of that is done now so now we
can start
messing around with our original data
set and using the ig approximation
we could do something arbitrary so for
illustration here i've decided to drop
out the 957th training data point
uh and our goal is to approximate the
parameters uh having dropped out the
957th training data point
so if you're going to do this remember
like all we have to do is take a weight
vector of all ones and set the 957th
coordinate to be zero so that's
basically what i'm doing here
and then we can call
the ij there's a function there's a
method in the ij
class
unfortunately also named ij in hindsight
we should have named it something more
informative
uh which takes uh as its input this
weight vector that i've just provided
that we have just created and outputs
the ig approximation to what the
parameters would be
and these parameters behave exactly the
same
as the parameters you'd get out of the
of running the set model
using the set procedure
so we can
set the logistic regressions parameters
to the ij approximation uh and then we
can ask for predictions from the
logistic regression model on the held
out data so since we had held out the
957th data point uh it will give you a
prediction on the 957 data point using
logistic regression.predict
so let's run this
and it does something so it gives us the
probability of class 1 as approximated
by ij is this value
so this value in itself does not mean
anything hopefully this is accurate so
one thing that you might want to do next
is to assess how accurate this
approximation is
so there's some theory which tells us
that increasingly uh increasing n as in
increasing the number of data points
and making small perturbations to the
weight vector guarantees uh provides
certain bounds on the error in the ij
approximation but we can also test it
out empirically for a particular data
set so in particular what you could
imagine doing is leaving out a few data
points
and
exactly refitting your model and
comparing the predictions made by the
exact refitted models with the
predictions made by the ig
approximations
uh so that's basically what's happening
in the sum for
here
for the sake of illustration i've
decided to pick the first 20 data points
we are going to leave each of these 20
data points one at a time
and do both the ig approximation and the
exact refit again since this is a very
small
data set
both uh
the exact refit is also fairly fast so
we can actually run this in live in real
time
and look at what happens
so
this is a scatter plot of predictions on
each of those 20 data points that we had
left out
the x-axis is the predicted value under
the exact approximation and the y-axis
for each of these red dots is the
predicted value under the infinitesimal
jackknife approximation
the closer uh this red dot is to the
diagonal line the better the match
between ij
the approximation and the exact
procedure you can also quantitatively
look at what the differences are in the
predictions and
there are some differences but these are
fairly small and again like since things
line up on the diagonal we can kind of
uh
we can see that these things are very
accurate
and again
as the number of data points increases
it's only going to get more accurate so
which is nice in a couple of different
ways one reason for you wanting to use
this kind of approximation is when you
have a lot of data points otherwise
maybe you could have just refit
exactly
and it turns out that in in specifically
in that regime where you have a lot of
data points these
these approximations become increasingly
accurate
all right so now uh
we run this approximation for a bunch of
different uh perturbed variants of the
data set and then we can ask it to make
predictions with each of those perturbed
parameters that i got from having fed
the put up data sets and that's what
this predict function would do it'll
give you the mean protection and a lower
bound and upper bound
the inter quantile range of this lower
bound and upper bound are specified
[Music]
through the configuration parameters up
here which i had skipped over a while
back so basically this alpha controls
the
tells you what lower bound and upper
bound to expect
so again so we can run this and it will
give you results as you would expect so
this guy in the middle is the mean
prediction and this is the lower bound
and the upper bound from having done the
infinite decimal jack knife
approximation to the exact chat line so
having left out one data point at a time
for all the thousand training data
points
and these are predictions on the test
set by the way
uh so i'm gonna speed up a little bit in
the interest of time
so again as i was suggesting in my
slides there's no reason to just delete
one data point we could do this with
more data points so here i've picked uh
20 random indices to set to zero so we
could do that and then we can
approximate the
parameters having left out these 20 data
points
one note of caution here is that
although this would be accurate the
farther away you move in the weight
vector space from the vector of all ones
since we are doing a taylor series
approximation about the vector of all
ones uh you would expect our accuracy to
go down so if you make a lot of the
coordinates zero maybe you wouldn't get
as accurate an approximation using ijs
as you would otherwise would have
uh and a quick note that
we don't have to have these weights be
binary not just zeros and ones we could
down weight up weight these weights
arbitrarily even have negative values
everything mechanistically will go
through you'd be able to run this code
it'll produce some set of parameters
it's less clear what
what your
how to interpret these parameters like
having a negative weight it's it's
unclear what exactly you're
approximating at that point but you
could do it if you have a good use case
for it
and then finally another plug
we can do these kinds of things for
structured models i wouldn't have the
time to go into it in this tutorial but
if you're interested check out this demo
again it's in the same folder as this
particular notebook
it walks you through on how to do this
for a hidden markov model
so with that i'll end uh i'll provide a
plug for my colleague jiri is going to
present next uh so these infinite
decimal jackknife style methods are
interesting and they're useful but they
do ask a lot of you as a user you need
to have access to the model
your model needs to be twice
differentiable you need access to the
training data so that you can compute
the hessian
if you don't have access to any of those
things it becomes tricky and it's
not not always clear how you you would
use these approximations so jerry in his
next bit of the talk uh next bit of this
tutorial we'll talk about black box
methods which are
very different from the stuff that we
talked about uh which allow you to do
that when when all you have access to
are the inputs and outputs of your model
but not the model itself
hello everyone um
i'm jiren aberteo
and i'm happy to walk you through the
third part
let me just start
sharing
all right so
we thought we will uh spend the
third third
to highlight couple more methods that
are featured in the uq360 toolkit that
are somewhat novel and very interesting
also from the practical perspective
and these two things are
um
the first one is a method which we refer
to as metamodeling
and the
second one is a metric that we believe
is a very useful tool in the assessment
of the quality
of uncertain quantification in
particular
prediction intervals in regression
so i'm going to start with the first one
the metamodeling method
[Music]
you may remember from prasanna's
presentation that
we when designing this toolkit we set
out
with one major high-level categorization
in mind
categorization of approaches
most uncertainty quantification
approaches can be classed into two bins
intrinsic and extrinsic
so while you heard that the intrinsic
approaches are those that
are based on models
that actually have the capability of
producing uncertainty quantification as
a byproduct of their parametric
structure and functions and what not
such as bayesian models and gaussian
processes ensembles are
there are many many examples in this
class the extrinsic approaches that you
see listed here
as a repeat
are based on the idea that we have a
pre-existing model that may or may not
have
the ability to produce
uncertainty
and we do something on top of it that's
why they are also called post talk or
they are actually referred to
in the class structure and uq 360 as
both talk
methods
i would like to take uh one
specific approach here that we
again call metamodeling
the idea here is that you have a base
model that is taking care of a task at
hand be it classification regression
ranking and whatnot structural
prediction
and now we have a secondary model
that acts as an observer
it gets to see the inputs and the
outputs of the base model
and it's trained to predict
the success rate or failure rate if you
will of the base model
okay
now there are several variants in one
simpler variant
the metamodel here the observer gets to
see only gets to see the input and the
output of the base model in s which we
refer to as black box setting and
in another variant it actually gets
access to the inner workings of the base
which might lead to an improved
uncertainty prediction and that is
referred to as white box
now why do we feel strongly about
and by the way i will be showing um a
quick demo of a particular
setting
of a black box metamodel
in
uh on a regression task
now we we do feel very strongly about
this
and that has several reasons uh first
and foremost this is a very practical
solution to many many
issues that
you know developers researchers are
faced with in practice when deploying ai
models
there are many cases where you are given
a model that has been trained by someone
else let's say you have a client's model
to which you don't really have any
reasonable access you cannot retrain it
um it may have been trained on large
amounts of potentially
proprietary data
but that model does not come with the
ability to produce its own uncertainty
but we know that uncertainty
quantification is a is basically a
number one um concern when we deploy ar
models
and
metamodeling is really
the solution that offers itself in
particular in the black box setting here
where you can equip that model without
needing any access to it
um besides that there are also
sort of related advantages
that are there are many so i just wanted
to pick
here one
that are based on the fact that you can
learn you can teach the meta model
to predict uncertainty or issues of the
base model when
you expose the base model to completely
new conditions for example out of domain
data
which is actually not necessarily
possible at training time of the
original base model
another advantage we might actually
mentioned is that
metamodeling can capture both uh data
and model uncertainty or
aleatric and epistemic uncertainty
and and finally
this method has been demonstrated to be
effective it is uh competitive to
state-of-the-art and and was shown
actually that in many settings it
outperformed a series of competitive
baselines
and i um put some references here for
you to follow if you're interested in
for the details
now in the toolkit
per se we
have
all of these metamodeling
versions deriving from one abstraction
that is the post hoc uq which you will
see if you have downloaded the toolkit
so you can either derive from there to
implement your own meta modeling
approach but we also provide two
main
flexible classes and one for
classification one for regression
that i will demonstrate now
so
let me see let me see before maybe going
into the notebook i just wanted to
mention briefly what is the sort of high
level interface so at instantiation time
the user
provides some kind of a specification of
the base model and the metamodel in
terms of structure what would you like
to have there um
as a meta model primarily but you can
bring your own base model and there are
three possible ways of specifying this
for each of these for base and meta
one way is naming it
and i will show you an example that
another way is providing a class
specification or class declaration
rather
and the third way is to provide an
actual pointer to an instance to an
existing instance
once
one of these classes is instantiated
there are two main public methods fit
and predicts with the obvious meanings
and this is by the way consistent with
other modules in uq 360.
this example notebook
exercises the regression
a regression task there is another
notebook for a classification task
and is stored in the folder
black box metamodel in uk 360 examples
black box metamodel okay so feel free to
follow through with the steps that i
will be doing
we are using a small regression task
based on house price prediction
or involving house price prediction
and i'm going to show
how easy it is to create a meta model
given a base model okay
so these steps are all obvious the main
line here is that we are
including importing the metamodel
regression class
from up360 the rest is just collaterals
then
loading the boston housing prices data
set which is a
relatively small data set
to play with
this is really just to show the process
of creating such a model rather than
focusing on performance so the
size of the data data set is really not
worrisome here
now i'm doing the classic
data science steps and splitting the
data set into training and tests
here just a quick
scatter plot of how the problem looks
like
there are multiple features in this data
set and the task is to it's a regression
task to predict a house price
we are now
choosing only a single feature as a
predictor as a covariate
and that is the number of rooms
in a house
you can see that there is a relatively
good amount of
correlation so we are good to go
a small routine to display some results
now this notebook per se
exercises all three instantiation
methods that i meant named by
declaration or by instance i'm gonna
just show quickly the first one by name
this is essentially a simple case like
you come and you say yeah i don't even
have a base model
um
i would like to create i would like this
class to actually create a base model
for me to do the regression as well as a
metamodel for me
now i can do that by simply relying on
predefined names
which we have several of them in this
class
gbr stands for gradient boosting
regression regressor
that i now choose for the base model as
well as the metamodel and as a user i
can also specify
um
certain parameters that i feel strongly
about i do not have to do it there will
be some defaults there
um that's the the really the simplest
way of
instantiating
a metamodel class so now it's a named uq
model that is the instance
now i'm
invoking the main public method the
first main public method fit
during which
all the
parameter fitting is done
so that is done now
and the second key method is predict so
now i'm providing to the as you could
see that during the fitting stage i have
both training and observations or the
actual ground truth here i'm invoking
the predict method with a batch of only
the features so that would be a number
of rooms
for samples this method returns just
like other
regression related methods returns the
regression
the regression prediction or the
regressive prediction the lower bound
and the upper bound and so
i'm often referring to lower and upper
bound as prediction interval
so that's just happened let's take a
look at the result
you see in this chart
in
solid orange
the regression prediction
points obviously are the test points and
upper and lower bounds
okay
now i'm going to skip the
method of uh
instantiating by declaration
and go to the more really the most
interesting practical scenario
where like i said before you have a
model as an instance
that model might be of
any type it doesn't have to be sk learn
model it it can be a client model the
only requirement that
we place on that instance is that it has
to be able to
it has to provide fit and predict
methods okay
so now i'm
simulating that
by creating a another gradient boosting
regression regressor here and calling it
base model
so this would be the
this is the simulation of the case where
okay
this model is trained on
a hundred hundred thousands of hours of
data or something like that
i'm also choosing to create an external
instance of a metamodel which is in this
case now a linear regression model
linear regressor with some configuration
now the key is that
i as a user
can pass
pointers to these instances into the
model metamodel regression
class okay
and i got that instance called uq model
again
i
performed the fit
and predict methods
okay and can display the results here
so this is really
a very simple walkthrough of the
essential steps that's really all there
is to
the very basic black box metamodeling we
have
abstractions for white box metamodeling
and
you know that that give you
give you the base classes for multiple
variants we also have a recent
set of recent additions to
to the uq 360
that implement performance prediction
and all kinds of interesting problems as
instances of metamodeling
now at this point
maybe
maybe we can have a couple of minutes
for questions before i move on to the
second part
uh so for this uh particular
uh model
you do you have to have the inputs and
the model but if you have just the model
output which is the model score you
cannot do anything with metamodel
you still can you still can it is um
the the features into the meta model
can be just the outputs of um
of the uh
regressor
ideally you do want to have let's say if
you if you take a look at the
classification problem might be a better
example if you have a
10 class classifier
that outputs you know and currently
the base model just takes the maximum
probability output as the class that it
predicts
you still can take the probabilities or
the logics of the ten classes as
features and feed them as feature
vectors into a meta model of your
choosing let's say a
logistic regressor
and
potentially get an improvement over or
basically it depends what you compare to
but you can get an improved quality of
of the uncertainty that comes out of the
metamodel
if that makes sense
i see
feeding it
feeding the features the inputs of
course gives the metamodel more chances
to perform well
but it is not required
it looks like dan dan g as a question
you can mute and mute yourself and ask
it directly
sure thank you yeah um i it looks like
the red upper bound lower bound is the
same
uh distance from the predicted in terms
of the y-axis at sort of every value of
number of rooms
is there a reason why around six where
there are more data points while the
bands aren't narrower
well in this case i would not even want
to go into interpreting these results on
this very very small data set and you
are right that
in this implementation the bounds are
symmetric
that doesn't mean that
the concept is limited to it in fact you
can have
um
separate metamodel or separate
components within the metamodel
to predict lower and upper bounds just
like you can have
similar you know set up with quantum
regression
so this class you will write has
predicts
or generates symmetric uncertainty
predictions prediction intervals
does that answer your question
yeah thank you okay yeah
yeah this is a very simple example i
mean i
think
going into the detail here into
interpreting like it does happen
with the gradient boosting regressor
that it does widen but
it's tricky
it's very small
so at this point i think it might make
sense if i uh
go to the second part
i would like to and i'm not sure how
much time i will have so i would like to
just uh
um bring this to your attention as an
interesting um
addition to the sort of toolbox
researchers toolbox
something we call
uncertainty characteristics curve
we believe that it's a very useful tool
but
we leave it up to you to decide there is
it has an implementation
in uq 360 accompanied by a
notebook that goes actually into detail
and walks you through
all the functionality i will just give
you a gist of what this is about
so often um and i think prasanna touched
on it
often we are dealing with the question
how do we
assess the quality of uncertainty
and in regression tasks
again we are talking about prediction
intervals lower and upper bound
what you typically see is some kind of a
notion of how
how well calibrated these
prediction intervals are
many papers in fact will give you the
notion of calibration in terms of
okay
we trained it to be 95
uh sort of uh coverage
and that's what happened on our hello
test set
but not much further information will be
given for example where these uh
intervals
um
[Music]
wide or narrow or
you know what was the mean bandwidth the
other metric
that is one type of problem that i see
the other type of problem is that people
when they when they do
coverage
coverage probability
uh they decide on a certain level of
confidence for example um 0.95
another work might actually decide on
0.9 or 0.99 and
that makes the work kind of not
necessarily not comparable but hard to
compare
so we now
refer to this type of settings like 0.95
as an operating point
and we attempted to
create a tool that
is agnostic with respect to this
operating point that is what uncertainty
characteristics curve is about
i have this very brief motivating
example imagine you have
um model a and model b both
uh generating prediction intervals
around some regression okay so you have
the same case
blue is
regression prediction oranges
observation and the um
gray or bluish area is prediction
intervals around it now i might be
tempted to say well i do want
i'd really prefer b because of the
coverage probability
i miss only maybe five percent of points
of my observations this is this is the
way to go
now of course i this is an artificial
example
if you now rescale the scenario and
scale up
the output of algorithm a
you get a scenario where you get an
outcome where you capture the the
observation
uh really nicely again this is an
artificially nice example where you
envelop the all of the observations with
minimal access in bandwidth okay
while if you scale down
[Music]
b's output that looked so good
you can see that um
there is really no signal in the shape
of the prediction interval it has
nothing to do with the observation shape
so
and in fact it has been it was generated
randomly
um
so it's
it's really if you think about it from
this perspective this would not be a
good prediction interval
now
i know this slide is busy
so i would like you to just concentrate
on
this bi-dimensional graph
now we have we already uh
had actually in somebody touched on it
in the chat
that
at any point
you
[Music]
with with the with regression and
prediction intervals
uh you will encounter two types of um
costs or incur two types of costs the
first one is
loosely speaking by overshooting the
observation
that is what we refer to as band excess
but it can be also measured by absolute
bandwidth of your prediction intervals
and at another point
we might undershoot and miss so that is
usually measured as the average miss
rate which is 1 minus
coverage probability
or we have a metric that
is more
of a soft
measure of that which is a deficit in
bandwidth okay
so now we have a bi-dimensional graph
with two axes on one axis is the type
one cost on the other axis type two cost
the uq 360 ucc implementation lets you
as a user actually choose among multiple
variants you can choose
what i call access or you can choose
absolute bandwidth
you can choose miss rate and this
band deficit but
overall the idea is that we now have an
axis system where we can see a trade-off
now how do we get that trade-off
we find a way to
scale
or yeah scale down or scale up inflate
or deflate
the other way around
the bands of the prediction interval so
that we can actually start with a very
thin sliver of a prediction interval
around the
regression prediction
and inflate it
all the way up so that it
envelops all of our observations within
a certain batch of data this is all
based on a
sample of data
such that our miss rate starts ranging
from almost 100 percent with that tiny
sliver we will be missing almost 100 of
our observations
and end up with a miss rate of zero as
we envelope all of the observations
so that gives rise to a set of
operating points
or a
basically a curve it's not dissimilar to
the receiver operating characteristics
curves
this curve gives us now a deeper insight
into the behavior of each model that
generates prediction intervals
there are often seen in practice
cases of crossovers of different models
meaning
model a might actually perform better in
a low miss rate
operating region but model b might be
the better one in a higher miss rate
region
so this tool
gives you that insight that's one
outcome the other one is
we calculate the area under such a curve
that gives us a scalar summary metric
of the performance
of a
prediction interval
model um that is
what we say operate operating point
agnostic
uh imagine you do not necessarily know
that
you don't have an application in mind
when you develop the algorithm or you
might have an application in mind but
you don't know what is the exact
operating region are we focusing on 0.99
coverage probability or is it more 0.8
so such a metric can give you
an agnostic view
and
might serve a more
general
comparison
in uq 360
[Music]
all the implementation is is uh height
in this class uncertainty
characteristics curve there are many uh
features
methods that are actually interesting
but there's no time to cover them
um
the
the area under the curve
we call it a uucc
is also
produced by a regression metrics which
is a class that will give you many many
[Music]
uq metrics
in
basically covering
some of the metrics that prasanna
mentioned so there you will see it as as
the area under the ucc and finally i
would like to point you to the demo
notebook which really walks you through
pretty much all of the functionality of
ucc
okay so
i think at this point we only have a
couple of minutes of prasanna
home control to you
yeah thank you uh thank you uh our
presenters today for joining uh pi data
thank you
chiri prasanna saw me yeah
definitely i learned a lot today about
the uk 360.
i think it's a good addition to
aif360 and the other set of tools from
ibm
you